kev loves watches i do who knew yes i
love watches kevin kev love watches so
we're comparing the hardware what do you
love kev what are you doing uh i am a ap
guy at heart uh adimar pk yes that's
sucker for craftsmanship more
importantly the open-faced world of
watches what are you featuring right now
well this is a skeleton this is a
this is a
that is so hot one out of 150 i believe
there's only 150 of these pieces made
this boy knows how to buy watches
because when there's only 150 the price
goes where oh that's right you're making
money that's right absolutely and you
bought it at retail absolutely no no you
have to be able to make smart purchases
and uh because of myself and my
relationships with these brands i'm able
to get in at cost and not uh go to the
secondary market and have to open so a
watch like this is up almost a hundred
percent that's why absolutely the key is
to really develop your brand with the
watchmakers because they want to give
you retail prices absolutely